[MUSIC PLAYING]
SETH VARGO: Hi there, and
welcome to the sixth episode
on SRE and DevOps.
My name is Seth, and
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And hi.
I'm Liz, a Site Reliability
Engineer or SRE at Google
where I teach Google
Cloud customers
how to build and operate
reliable services.
So Seth, I have an
error budget now.
And it's based on a
level of reliability
that my customers
expect, but I don't
want to have to wait months
to find out whether or not I'm
going to meet my error budget.
SETH VARGO: Definitely.
Collecting all of that
data can be time consuming.
That's why you need
a Risk Analysis.
LIZ FONG-JONES: A risk what?
SETH VARGO: An analysis of
what items or risks that might
cause you to not meet your SLO.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I see, yeah.
I know all the ways that my
system has failed in the past.
And I can think of
many different ways
that my system might
fail in the future.
But how does that
help me figure out
if my error budget is realistic?
SETH VARGO: So you
need to figure out
how often each failure
is likely to happen
and how severe it will be
if and when it happens.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I see.
But that still doesn't
help me compare the impact
on my error budget.
How do I know if a high severity
but infrequent form of outage
is better or worse than
a frequent but low level
degree of degradation?
SETH VARGO: Right.
So that's actually the secret.
You just have to multiply
those metrics together.
Here, let me show you.
Tell me about one of your common
incidents or failure modes
that you're worried about.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
So for example, I
have a primary database that
I have to backup every month.
And it takes the entire
database down for two hours
every, single time.
SETH VARGO: So that means that
your time between failures
is roughly 30 days every
month and that your impact
duration is 120 minutes.
It also impacts your entire user
base, since during that time,
the entire system is offline.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
That makes sense.
SETH VARGO: So that means you'd
have about 120 minutes times 12
months times 100%
of your user base
which is about 1,440
bad minutes per year.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
And my error budget
says that I'm
supposed to achieve
2 and 1/2 nines or 99.5%
reliability over the year,
meaning that I can have about
2,600 bad minutes per year.
SETH VARGO: Right.
So that means your monthly
database downtime is consuming
half of your error budget.
But I'm sure that's not the only
kind of downtime you're seeing.
LIZ FONG-JONES: No.
As an example, every
couple of weeks people
complain that the system is
slow on Friday afternoons,
because everyone is
trying to build and test
their code before they
go home for the weekend.
SETH VARGO: Yeah,
that happens in, like,
every software development shop.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So it's so slow
that it causes half our users
to be unhappy with us.
And what's worse is it takes
us half an hour for the support
tickets to come in
and then half an hour
to actually provision
more capacity.
So that is probably
not very good, right?
SETH VARGO: Yeah, so
if I were to put this
into the same framework,
I'd say that this
is a 60 minute outage,
30 minutes to detect
and 30 minutes to resolve,
times 26 times per year,
affecting about half
of your user base.
And that's 780 bad
minutes per year.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Right.
So this outage could
wind up being about half
as bad as the database
backup downtime.
So that makes a lot of sense.
SETH VARGO: Great.
So we can fill out
these calculations
together for any other
sources of outages
that you'd like to catalog.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Great,
I'll get right to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LIZ FONG-JONES: OK, whew.
Now I'm done with that.
SETH VARGO: So now that you've
compiled all of the risk data,
we can sort the outages by the
number of bad minutes per year.
Indeed, as we suspected,
the monthly database outage
is consuming the majority
of your error budget.
Combined with these other
small sources of outages,
it's clear that you're going
to exceed your error budget.
LIZ FONG-JONES: That's
not really good.
SETH VARGO: Well, but
it's not all bad news.
Since we've gathered
our estimates
and quantified this
data, we can find out
what things will bring us
back under the error budget.
For instance, anything
that consumes about 25%
of the error budget
or more is something
that we want to address.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
That makes sense.
And if I address all
of the large risks
and I still wind up
exceeding my error
budget, what do I do then?
SETH VARGO: So then you need
to pick a combination of risks
to address that will bring
you within the budget, not
necessarily all of
the largest ones.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Right,
because some of the larger
risks I can't necessarily
address without rewriting
the whole system.
That will take time.
So you're saying that
if I accumulate enough
of these smaller
things and fix them,
that will potentially bring me
back within my error budget.
SETH VARGO: Right.
So now you have a plan for
how to estimate risk and a way
to create plans to stay
within your error budget.
Alternatively, if there's no way
to mitigate all of that risk,
you now have numerical
evidence to go back
to your key
stakeholders to revisit
the possibility of a different
SLO that would give you
a larger error budget.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Thanks, Seth.
And thanks to everyone
for watching this episode.
Hopefully this is
helpful for teams
trying to put DevOps
into practice through SRE
techniques.
I'm really excited
to figure out how
to set up effective
alerts for our service,
so we can know whether
we're in danger of violating
our SLOs on the next episode.
SETH VARGO: Hey Liz, what's
that button down there?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Oh,
that's the Like button.
You should press it,
if you enjoyed this.
SETH VARGO: And
this one over here?
LIZ FONG-JONES: That's
the subscribe button,
so you can find out when
we post our next episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]